هذا ملياردير امريكي ورجل اعمال ينفق
مليوني دولار سنويا في محاوله لوقف التقدم
في العمر واعاده عقارب الساعه الى الوراء
اجتهد براين خلال الشهر الماضي بعدما اجرا
اول
تمزمه دم
متعدد عندما تلقى دم ابنه الشاب ليتبرع
بعدها برايمبل لوالده البالغ 70 عاما
براين يبلغ من العمر 45 عاما ولديه فريق
مكون من اكثر من 30 طبيبا يجرون الفحوصات
الدوريه بشكل روتيني لمتابعه اعضاء جسده
ويتبع نظاما غذائيا صارما اما حاليا يدعي
براين انه يملك قلب رجل يبلغ 37 عاما
وبشره شخص بعمر 28 عاما وليا قد شاب بعمر
18 عاما بتذكر بالصحافه الاجنبيه العنوان
كان لهاي القصه انه اكثر رجل يقوم بفحوصات
في العالم والهدف تبعه كان انه يوصل يعني
عمره بيولوجيا يوصل لعمر ابنه يتساوى مع
ابنه بالعمر ابن عمره 16 سنه شفت الرجال
شلون يفكرون لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات